You're in so many of our favorite movies.
And I just thought, as I'm checking off your IMDb list,
like literally going
is there any chance we could get a glimpse
of a detail of some of these movies
and some stories in them.
And we wanna try something called behind the scenes.
(audience applauds)
Okay, a detail, an insider fly on the wall moment.
Anything that comes to mind when I say "Animal House".
Oh, my first movie, I mean, I was 19.
One thing I remember really well is
the whole experience was completely overwhelming for me.
And my very last shot,
I was lying in this cutout on the sidewalk
and looking up at this flock of birds floating by.
And I was just kinda overwhelmed with emotion,
thinking about the fact
that this magical experience was about to end,
but also that it was the beginning of a life time
in movies and how grateful I was for that.
One that is so near and dear to our hearts, "Diner".
You know, "Diner" was one of those movies
where the experience was so fantastic.
And in fact, me and the "Diner" guys are still in touch.
We were just emailing about some dumb joke
that we kind of pass around between each other.
And we really did form a bond
while we were doing that movie.
And I'll never forget it.
It was an amazing experience.
I mean, I would be remissed if I didn't throw in
although I did feel like I just got a juicy story
about Quincy Jones and "Footloose", but "Footloose".
It was challenging, certainly physically
I wasn't trained as a dancer.
And so try and do those moves.
But again, what an opportunity
and it's just one of those things
that just changes your life.
Okay, I have to include this
because it's one of the best movies ever made
by one other than John Hughes, but please give me a detail
about "Planes, Trains, and Automobiles".
Well, I had done, "She's Having a Baby" with John
and I knew that his next movie
was gonna be "Planes, Trains and Automobiles."
And so I loved working with him so much
that I said to him, "So listen,
if you got anything at all for me
in "Planes, Trains and Automobiles"
I don't care what it is I'll just do it."
And he called me up and said,
"I want you to be an extra in the movie.
You're gonna race for a cab with Steve."
And I was like, "Okay, that sounds great."
Okay well that leads me into, "She's Having a Baby".
Please tell me something about that.
Oh, wow.
"She's Having a Baby" was a very intense.
John worked incredibly long hours,
but I remember he was a giant music fan John
and was constantly finding bands.
He had his own record label
and was really, really instrumental in a lot of young acts.
And he had found that Kate Bush song for the-
"This Woman's Work"
And he played it during the scene
where I'm waiting to find out
whether or not my wife has delivered our child.
And it just hit me every single time.
Okay one last one, "A Few Good Men".
To be in the company of Nicholson, who
when I started out as a kid, he was one of my heroes.
The thing I really loved about Jack
and the thing that I've always tried to sort of emulate is
he was one of the first actors that I ever saw
that seemed as though
he didn't really care what people thought of him.
And yet he was such a movie star and so dynamic.
So to be on the set with him, along with Tom
and Demi and on and on.
It was a great experience.
Yeah again I love doing it.
Drew, I mean, I'll tell you,
when I think back, you name these movies
and all I can think to myself is
about how much I really do love being an actor
and how grateful I am,
that I've been able to have these experiences,
work with these people
and the be able to get paid
for doing something that I love so much.
I'm so glad you feel that way.
(upbeat music)